tenemos aquí tres desigualdades que
involucran el valor absoluto y debajo de
cada una de ellas tenemos tres posibles
valores que puede tomar x ahora lo que
yo quiero que hagamos en este vídeo es
ver cuáles de estos posibles valores de
x hacen que esta desigualdad sea cierta
vamos a empezar con esta desigualdad así
es que hay que pensar en cuáles de estos
tres valores hacen que esta desigualdad
sea cierta y bueno lo primero que me
salta a la vista y por cierto te
recomiendo que lo pongas pausa el vídeo
y lo intentes por tu cuenta pero lo
primero que me salta a la vista es que
esta expresión de aquí se puede
simplificar bastante porque podemos
saber cuál es el valor absoluto de menos
7 menos 7 está a una distancia de 7
enteros del 0 y por lo tanto el valor
absoluto de menos 7
es 7 o también podemos pensarlo de otra
forma podemos pensarlo como que el valor
absoluto de cualquier número es la
versión no negativa de ese número aunque
ello sea 7 y por lo tanto una
desigualdad equivalente a esta
desigualdad es que el valor absoluto de
x sea menor que 7 entonces pues vamos
con el primer posible valor de x menos 8
lo que tenemos que hacer es ver si esta
desigualdad es cierta
cuando x es igual a menos 8 aunque hoy
vamos a volver a escribir esta
desigualdad por aquí pero siempre que
aparezca una x por ahí vamos a poner
menos 8
ok así es que nos preguntamos si el
valor absoluto de menos 8 que es la x es
menor que 7 y esta desigualdad es cierta
pues veamos el valor absoluto de menos 8
1 8 y 8 no es menor que 7 entonces este
valor de x no hace que esta desigualdad
sea cierta y ahora vamos con el
siguiente valor posible de x aunque
entonces siempre que veamos una equis
vamos a poner un -2 el valor absoluto de
x o sea menos todos tienen que ser menor
que 7 menor que 7 y esta desigualdad es
cierto pues el valor absoluto de menos 2
es simplemente un 2
pues 2 si es menor que 7 entonces
x igual a menos 2 si satisface esta
desigualdad aunque bueno y ahora veamos
qué pasa con x igual a 6 el valor
absoluto de 6 aunque hay porque en
cualquier lugar de la desigualdad donde
aparece una equis estamos poniendo 6
entonces queremos saber si el valor
absoluto de 6 es menor que 7 menor que 7
y pues el valor absoluto de 636
6 si es menor que 7 entonces
x 6 si satisface esta desigualdad
tanto x igual a menos 2 como x 6
satisface una desigualdad o sea menos 2
y 6 estos 2 enteros hacen que esta
desigualdad sea cierta pero bueno ahora
vamos con la siguiente desigualdad
queremos saber para cuáles de estos tres
valores el valor absoluto de x es mayor
que 5 y como siempre te recomiendo que
le pongas una pausa y lo intentes por tu
cuenta aunque yo empezamos con x igual a
menos 4 nos preguntamos si el valor
absoluto de menos 4 es mayor que 5 y el
valor absoluto de menos 4 es un 4 y pues
4 no es mayor que 5 entonces
x igual a menos 4 no satisface esta
desigualdad no hace que esta desigualdad
sea cierta
y ahora vamos con x igual a 3 aunque
siempre que veamos una equis la vamos a
sustituir por 3 el valor absoluto de 3
es mayor que 5
esta desigualdad cierta
pues el valor absoluto de 3 es
simplemente 303 no es mayor que 5
entonces
x igual a 3 no satisface esta
desigualdad y llegamos a x igual a menos
9 y queremos saber si el valor absoluto
de menos 9 es mayor que 5
aunque el valor absoluto de menos 9 es 9
que definitivamente si es mayor que 5
entonces
x igual a menos 9 si satisface esta
desigualdad aunque si hace que esta
desigualdad sea cierta
y finalmente llegamos a la última
desigualdad y queremos saber para cuáles
de estos valores xy el valor absoluto de
x es mayor que menos 16 pero resulta que
hay un detalle es súper interesante
puedes tú decirme ahorita algún número
cuyo valor absoluto no sea mayor que
menos 16
darme algún número x que no cumpla esta
desigualdad piénsalo un momento qué pasa
con todos los valores absolutos hay
algún número cuyo valor absoluto sea
negativo pues claro que no ok
el valor absoluto de cualquier número es
o cero o es positivo positivo
walker y bueno esto de que un número sea
cero o positivo también lo podemos
llamar no negativo pero el chiste es que
el valor absoluto de cualquier número
siempre va a ser o cero o algo más
grande algo positivo y cualquier cosa
que siempre sea mayor o igual a cero
siempre va a ser mayor que algún número
negativo como menos 16 entonces en
realidad esta desigualdad se da para
todos los números x ni siquiera tenemos
que evaluar esta desigualdad en estos
valores de x ya sabemos qué
se va a dar esta desigualdad sin embargo
si vamos a evaluar estos valores de x en
esta desigualdad sólo para verlo
rápidamente pero en general para
cualquier número x su valor absoluto es
positivo o 0 y entonces siempre va a ser
mayor que menos 16 y listo esta
desigualdad siempre va a ser cierta pero
pues veamos lo rápido aunque si ponemos
x igual a menos 15 entonces tenemos el
valor absoluto de menos 15 y queremos
ver que es mayor que menos 16 pero el
valor absoluto de menos 15 es 15 que es
un número positivo y por lo tanto es
mayor que menos 16 y lo mismo pasa con
cualquier otro número si ponemos x igual
a 3 el valor absoluto de 3 queremos ver
que es mayor que menos 16 pero el valor
absoluto de 3
3 otra vez que definitivamente es mayor
que menos 16 aunque porque los números
positivos siempre son mayores que los
números negativos y finalmente x igual a
9 aunque el valor absoluto de 9 queremos
ver que es mayor que menos 16 y claro
que sí aunque porque el valor absoluto
de 9 es 9 que también es mayor que menos
16 incluso si tuviéramos 0 aquí el valor
absoluto de 0 es 0 pero el 0 sigue
siendo mayor que menos 16 aunque esta
desigualdad es cierta para todos los x
incluyendo menos 15 3 y 9